you guys it's max today we're gonna be
comparing two headphones so you guys
have been asking us about both them are
a premium they both have active noise
cancellation we have the Sony WH 1000 X
m3s
and the new beats solo Pro we're gonna
look at variety of things such as sound
quality the noise cancellation of course
battery life comfort build quality and
more let's start out with the cases
themselves they both come with these
nice cases the Sony's is slimmer it's
not as thick but it's much wider and
it's more of a hard case whereas the be
solo pros come with this very soft nice
feeling case but it's not a hard case so
it's not going to give you the level of
protection and this means that if you're
going to be traveling you could easily
shove this into your bag the empty space
can just kind of compress like this so
it doesn't take up that much room on the
inside we just have the beats solo Pro
headphones and nothing else inside of
here it whereas with the Sony's they
come with a variety of accessories
included we have a headphone cable here
a regular headphone cable so if you want
to use these plugged into your laptop
without bluetooth and we also have this
little adapter for different airlines
now they do look different you have a
lot of color options with the beats but
one thing that I am really interested in
is the sticker right here it says fold
to power on and off button peel this off
as soon as you open it up like that that
will actually power on the headphone
itself that h1 chip makes it very easy
to pair you just open these up and then
you'll get a little pop up I'm already
connected I'm also on the beta version
of iOS so the icon looks a little bit
different but it makes it really easy to
pair it also makes there be almost no
lag as far as watching videos and
playing games it really improves that it
also syncs to all of your other iCloud
devices so if you use an iPhone it's
really nice to have that
now the Sony's are more traditional you
do have a standard power button right
here press on hold and the first time
will start Auto pairing and then after
that if you want to pair you press and
hold it for longer and you also do have
a companion app on your phone that you
would download and then you can actually
connect them with the app instead of
going into your Bluetooth settings and
then in
app itself we can change the modes that
we're in we could do some optimizations
for surround sound we have access to an
EQ which is nice there's a lot of
different options in here
now the Sony's also have this little NFC
logo meaning if you are on a phone that
supports the Android phones
you actually tap them if you have the
NFC on there and then it will auto start
the process probably to download the app
and to get them connected now as far as
connectivity the Sony's use USB type-c
to charge and then of course we have
this input for a cable whereas the beats
they have a lightning jack once again
because Apple bought them out
I do wish that these use USB type-c
instead now just like what the air pods
if you're using a device that doesn't
support the h1 chip for pairing you just
press and hold on the button and it will
start your traditional bluetooth pairing
process so now let's talk about the
build quality and then we'll get into
comfort now I am pretty surprised by how
nice these feel they have some good
weight to them this is the matte version
so everything is this nice soft smooth
finish and then the little headband
portion over here is rubber and so also
guys a little air gap in there when I
press down it does feel pretty nice and
then the actual plastic on the outsides
also feels pretty premium with aluminum
here now it's also interesting that this
whole little earphone portion it's
connected inside but it's also suspended
by a little bit of rubber material all
around so there's no gaps or anything
else like that and then the actual
portion that goes over your ear these
are over ear style it has this kind of a
memory foam here instead of a
traditional type of foam so that's
interesting now I've been using the Sony
as a much longer these are larger they
are over here so we have that difference
in the way it's built but the plastic
doesn't feel as nice we don't have any
aluminum or anything else it's all
plastic and it looks and feels like more
traditional and then same thing with the
headband you have standard foam with
this leather fake leather type of cover
with the Sony's the foam that is on the
ear cup is definitely firmer but it is
around the ear so it doesn't have to be
as soft as the
with the beat now both of these have
pretty good battery life the Sony's are
rated at 30 hours with noise
cancellation on the beats are rated at
22 hours there's no worry eating for the
sonia's with it off but they beats if
you don't have the octave noise
cancellation you'll get about 40 hours
so that's more than good enough now if
your battery does run low you can fast
charge both of these in 10 minutes
you'll get three hours of use with the
beats in five hours of use with the
Sony's now let's go ahead and test out
comfort I'm gonna start out with the
Sony's I'm quite familiar these have
been using them for a while open up the
headband and the really good benefit
with the Sony's is the fact that they're
over the ear so they're not pressing
down on your ear right now with the
Beats I have not used these yet
I guess we'll try it out right now but
these are over the ears design as far as
style so definitely not as comfortable
and I don't feel a lot of pressure on my
ears because the pads are pretty soft
and they're like a memory foam but it
definitely has more pressure than the
Sony's where they barely touch your ears
at all so now let's go ahead and do a
sound quality comparison so I'm using
tidal listening to master quality tracks
and I'm gonna start out with a hip-hop
song and then I'll give you guys my
opinions then go into an electronic song
and then a rock song
all right well I have my personal
verdict I don't think either one of
these are perfect unless you EQ them
which you have the ability to but I
would lean towards the beats the bass
sounds a lot more controlled it sounds
more accurate and it's complementing the
other sounds instead of taking them over
of course you can't turn the bass down
but especially in this this rock song
where we get into a lot of the drums it
sounds a little bit loose with the
Sony's the beats if you max out the
volume they definitely do get louder
especially if there's a lot of high
notes now another thing that would deem
pointed out is that he can hear the
music coming from the Sony's way more
even though they're quieter they leak a
lot more sound and there's actually
ports here on the side so he was clearly
able to hear all the different vocals
that I was Lucas from the songs I was
listening to
we're from the beats at max volume he
only heard of some of the high
frequencies everything else he did
nearly here and he couldn't make out the
word so if you care about your privacy
of what you're listening to and you're
gonna be cranking up the volume the
beats keep a lot more of that sound in
so if I had to choose between these
headphones as far as sound quality
surprisingly and unexpectedly I would go
with the beats but of course that is not
the only reason why you choose
headphones a big reason why people are
asking us between these two is the noise
cancellation now we know the Saudis are
great I'm gonna put them on and try them
out once again and then we'll test out
how good are the beats and do they get
close can they compete so I have noise
cancellation turned on he and putting
pee talk okay I hear but definitely much
quieter and a lot more of the low noise
surprisingly the highs are taken out hmm
talk with him but he was definitely
louder okay well I went back and forth
the many times between both of these and
this is a bit unexpected
both these do a fantastic job and the
Sony's are great but Elise in this
environment the beats are cutting out a
little bit more for me now both of them
cut out the central air exactly the same
I can't hear what
either one of these so maybe there's a
chance if you're on an airplane where
you have more that low-end sound the
Sony's might kick that out and kind of
remove that a little bit better than the
beads but the beats do remove the high
sounds both from my voice from Adina's
voice and a little bit of the air coming
in through the vents I actually hear
some of that air it's a little bit lower
sounding and a little bit quieter with a
beats which I would not expect yeah so I
don't think you can go wrong with either
one of them but if you're thinking about
getting the beats or maybe if you're
thinking about not getting them because
you think that the noise cancellation
isn't as good
I would not be holding that against them
the noise cancellation works very well
now another thing that you have to
consider is the ambient mode or the
transparency mode both these have these
features and Vadim I hear you but it is
more muffled than the air pods Pro I
still have been blocking out a lot of
sound where I know where that's not a
comparison between the air pods pro but
what though is you hear pretty much
everything now let's put this on and now
but even go ahead and talk your voice
sounds more natural I'm getting more of
the high-end sound maybe because these
speakers are two more for high-end for
the ambient mode if you care about it
it's sounding as natural as possible I
would say the beats are a little bit
better now of course both of these
headphones have microphones built into
them and if you're gonna use them for
phone calls for FaceTime or other uses
you're gonna want good quality audio so
let's go ahead and compare them this is
a microphone quality test using the Sony
headphones the 1000x m3s
and this is the sound quality using the
beats solo Pro let me know down in the
comments section which one has a better
microphone now we also have some
differences in terms of controls both of
them have buttons on the left hand side
so you can toggle between your noise
cancellation and then on the right hand
side is where you control them now the
beats have physical buttons so if you
want to adjust the volume we can press
up or press down and you get this little
click sound from the physical keys and
then if you want to invoke sear you just
press and hold or because of the h1 chip
you can actually just say hey Siri now
with the Sony's all of our controls are
also on the right hand side but it is a
touch
panel that means you don't have physical
keys you just slide your finger across
this way if you want to skip a song or
go back to Reverse
you can also press the pause and you can
increase volume decrease volume it does
feel kind of more futuristic nicer or
not to have to click but because of the
touch panel I have had some accidental
presses if I'm trying to make some
adjustments or do anything else
skipping songs and then sometimes if I
try to decrease volume I'll actually
skip a song instead of doing that so I
think even though it's kind of cooler
more futuristic it is a little bit less
convenient alright guys so now let's
talk about prices the Sony's MSRP for
350 dollars compared to 299 for the
beats now of course prices do vary so
we'll have the best deals linked down
below if you guys buy through that link
that helps support the channel that is
greatly appreciated so we don't have a
big difference in price so Sonia gives
you a little more value with that cable
built in instead of having to buy it
separately if you would choose so with
the beats but testing these side-by-side
and comparing them I am quite surprised
I'm more impressed with a beast than I
thought I would now a lot of agree is I
kind of preferred the beats even though
these are not my headphones I don't want
to sound like a bias towards them these
are actually my head problems so I'm
choosing the beats in certain areas but
I think it comes down to a couple things
first off if you're gonna wear them for
say five hours at a time
the Sony's are gonna be more comfortable
whereas the beasts the fact that they're
over the ear they're less comfortable
for long periods of time although they'd
actually did a pretty good job now the
other thing is if you're on android or
iOS
now with the Sony's it doesn't really
matter the technology the sames the app
is the same but with the beads if you
already are using an iPhone everything
is integrated the switching the the
ambient modes with noise cancellation
that's integrated having access to that
w1 chip and hey Siri supports and even
the Lightning jack that is built into
this it's really designed for iPhone
users so if you're well if you have an
iPhone and you don't mind the over year
design I would personally go for the
beats and if you're an Android user then
I think it's a little bit more have a
harder choice but in that case I might
go with the Sony's especially if you
want an over ear design
overall I was not expecting for the
beats to do as good as they did I
thought the Sony's would smoke em but
this kind of changed my mind a little
bit
let me know down in comments section
which one you would rather choose and if
you buy one of these so why you bought
those if you guys want to see more
videos like this one click that little
circle above to subscribe and down below
to enable notifications has been max
with Max heck and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]